i'm angela mccaffrey i'm patrick clark
well and you're supposed to be angela
yes changing the name soon another thing
we have not gotten around to we have
been together for eight years and
married one this is tommy we haven't
been outside in like two years yeah
patrick works in the basement like a
garden gnome and a troll of sorts with
no windows and i own two businesses that
i'm trying desperately to keep afloat in
the middle of a pandemic
with this baby so we have let go of
ourselves we look crazy and we need your
help and we're so grateful to be
considered we hope to see you soon make
us over
so obviously we're here with group crew
member extraordinaire zanna roberts
rossi to help zanna what are some tips
to keep ourselves falling
into that rut
it's
so easy to fall into a style rut and
there's a few really practical tips i
like to use number one pick a style muse
could be someone on social media it
could be a celebrity literally analyze
what they wear think about the color the
silhouette the shape and copy it it's
that simple just buy the look they're
always affordable versions and another
great tip is actually and you have to be
a little bit brave for this but find
your best dressed friend or someone in
the family who's got good style and say
make me over
just do it you will be surprised they
will come up with ideas you would never
in a million years have tried on your
own all right well i'm so excited to see
what you've done is everybody ready for
the big reveal first we have patrick
and here is what patrick looked like
before
i think patrick looks great
but i'm excited to see how patrick looks
now
[Applause]
oh my god thank you thank you shut up no
okay i i'm just going to be super honest
with you and i hope that your wife feels
the exact same way i thought you know
what you look fine you don't need to do
anything when i saw your picture you
come out and you look so attractive and
i think your wife is gonna be so pleased
um
dana what did you do you just nailed it
it's literally that it's like fashion
and function together it's these utility
pieces clean black super flattering i
love the idea it feels a little bit
street wear a nice knit underneath as
well no scrappy t-shirts no dodgy
necklines you want something that looks
a little bit more elevated underneath so
this is a nice knit clean black pant
can't go wrong with that and a white
sneaker and if you're gonna wear a white
sneaker boys make sure it's clean and
crisp and looks like a freshie okay
how do you feel patrick because that's
always my biggest question how do you
feel i feel amazing i feel hip i feel
good yeah that's it
yeah i was like
thank you i feel it's like uh
a new lease on life i feel like you
really need to make sure that you look
and feel good even when you're working
from home because a great yeah yeah
because you get do you do get in this
rut and i think if you dress a little
bit more from on the outside then you're
going to feel a little bit more
confident inside you're going to have a
bit more motivation to go do stuff right
yeah exactly
absolutely absolutely are you excited
for your wife yeah i'm a little freaked
out
because i'm amazed what they've done
with me i can't wait to see what they've
done oh just you wait my friend just you
know well okay we haven't seen angela
yet but here is what she looked like
before
is it true patrick that your wife hasn't
cut her hair in 20 years yeah yeah 20
years well i can't think of a bigger
gift to new parents than a new little
lease on life when it comes to each
other angela come on out
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you look so beautiful first of
all i cannot stop staring at your lips i
know you thank you and your hair is
phenomenal i mean i wish you'd taken a
picture of the amount of hair that was
on the floor after this haircut it's
like two feet of air on the floor it's
like a new version of me which is how
much real easy i think as well to manage
you know you've got you've got a lot oh
look
oh
yeah it's amazing it's like i feel like
it sounds cheesy but young again like
i really get lost in the like
how much milk did i pump did you change
his diaper like you know all that and
now i'm like like this is like how we
were when we met absolutely i'm gonna
cry so
well now you have got the fabulous
outfits thanks to you thank you so where
are you going to take it out for a spin
first
that's a really well you tell me yeah
i think uh probably
a steakhouse but
all right
let's hold him to it
i'd be happy with the deli but a
steakhouse works too
you dressed the part for the date now
let's get you on one thank you so much
thank you so much
[Music]
you